Gary's about to give $1400 to someone to
go to a Knick game and say courtside
with death you got your perspective
[Music]
it's all the same game who can ever get
close to the customer then what you have
it and the ultimate thing is gonna play
out on voice this is like things are
gonna happen on voice Alexa I need this
who the hell wants to look something up
on Google that's that's why MetLife
rents good like Snoopy right that's why
chase pace Serena Williams or buys the
naming rights to the new warrior Stadium
like when you get real big you can
afford to do these things that make you
top of the funnel it's worth the risk
it's like in buying insurance like
everybody like as a human has insurance
right now highly unlikely you're gonna
use most of it right but nobody does the
same thing for their businesses does
brand right the gray not the black and
white everyone's in sales you know every
leader she or he has to reverse engineer
themselves right like so for example
some people look for DNA that are I need
a killer and she's gonna sell and we're
a boilerplate Wall Street [ __ ] and
I'm that and you're that and that's what
I'm looking for and that person she's
spitting on people in the in the phone
group to get them to sell more and that
[ __ ] leader loves that I fire her so
the answer to question is you need to
know what you're about from an EQ IQ
money long-term continuity I'd much
rather have a be who wants to be here
for seven and a half years than a super
a that wants to be here for 14 months
this is about ideas and making right
this is eliminating subjectiveness and
meetings and things that nature at the
end which is why we went with the
literal naming of it the volume of
content is the biggest need for anybody
that wants to communicate whether you're
a PTA member trying to raise money or
the biggest brain in the world like the
volume of content contextual to the
distribution
with the result on the back end of it is
the model and whoever gets there first
and best will disproportionately
successful in the communications
landscape which is why we have embarked
on this here we go
Madison Square Garden me and you the
winner I love this Jets Bank the winner
of the Knicks Wolves sit-down session
from barstools podcast is Matt Calderon
from Matt looking forward to it grew up
watching the Knicks with my mother who
was a lifelong fan because of her father
lost my mom to cancer in 2012 but shared
many great Nick moments with her when
they were good in the 90s waiting for
them to be good again take me I'm taking
you Matt I'm taking yeah I think it's
always a bad time you can force the
stuff so when you wanted to fill me but
I had things on my mind that I knew I
had to communicate to employees or I
don't even remember we'll see the
footage when I watch the blog I'll know
like yeah I mean forced to get never
makes sense like like Caleb wants
content that's his job and I'm 98% I'm
super there but I just couldn't get
there like I really had to address the
issues at hand there like when you're
not feeling it you're not feeling it and
so like you know obviously you want to
be honest whenever you can you want to
perform when you have to do but like
especially when you're vlogging or
making content there's always tomorrow
those always six hours from now there's
always right now where I do feel it and
I want to explain to you like this is
where characters in a good job like
that's not you haven't seen that too
often but it's a it's a truth there like
truth aside [ __ ] on my mind that I had
to address I need to be really focused
and this is very pass them to me that's
why I can always be miked but like that
moment was like yeah just not now and
that's okay because almost everything's
okay stop judging yourself hey guys
thank you so much for watching my video
on YouTube I wanted to jump in here at
the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now
and sign up for a subscription whether
it's a three pack whether it's a six
pack or whether it's a whole case of
each for the year if you drink 36
bottles of wine a year or give away 36
bottles of wine a year please sign up
for club empathy this project means the
world to me that could really use your
support
[Music]
you